Cora?
Oh my gosh, look at you!
What does your mom think about you coming to stay?
She thinks it's a great idea.
Sup?
Cora, this is Chicka and this is Tom.
How are you doing?
Come on!
When was the last time you went swimming?
In the ocean?
I missed most of my childhood so I could be where you wanted me.
I fit into your life and now I'm doing something on my own terms.
Cora, you can't just always run away.
I am not running away!
I am running towards something else,...
...something on my own terms.
These are really good.
Thank you.
Our family makes strong women and you're one of them.
Be proud of that.
Open your eyes and go, Cora, go!
Things happen and they change us and we can't control them.
What you can control is how they change you.